but then i see this guy
literally index fingers to both areolas
and starts rubbing his own nipples and
i'm like
in my drunk state of mind i'm like this
is normal this is cool
i like it i think it's quirky this is
[ __ ] normal
you're just drunk freesia and this is
normal but then
still we were we're going he was still
rubbing his own nipples and like getting
off on it i'm like
okay frieza this is not normal
is [ __ ] weird um but maybe it's just
because he's drunk so i just
i didn't finish but i let him finish and
then we went to sleep
next morning we wake up he wants to go
for the second round morning sex type of
situation
and i'm like in five four three two
one hola everybody how are you doing
today this is the genius brain podcast
for those of you who are first time
listeners
i apologize this podcast is literally
about nonsense
and we have a very interesting guest
today we have my young friend
freesia park let's get it i knew you
were going to say that
you're going to say that [ __ ] god you
get the
[ __ ] out of here yo i'm honestly a true
fan of this podcast and i texted you
this before
but when i first moved into my chelsea
studio in manhattan
i was pretty freaking lonely i no longer
had a roommate so i was like huh
what should i turn on and i started
turning on your podcast and it made me
feel like
i had someone to eat with i had my
friend with me that is the
saddest thing i've ever heard in my life
you big loser
yo i swear everybody listens to podcasts
when they're
either just walking or eating because
they just need some conversation and
stimulus i say
i call you a loser but that's literally
what i do yeah
when i'm walking or if i'm just out and
you grab something to eat
i always listen to a podcast hell yeah
it's just nice to listen to uh
somebody just have a conversation around
you it's really fun
so i brought her on today because for
all my
uh young listeners out there or maybe
some of you out there who are single
right i know you guys are having a lot
of like relationship issues
and i am always counseling this little
[ __ ] all the [ __ ] time
you have no idea right when i'm flying
into new york beer i'm like all right
lay it on me lay it on me who's the new
guy this girl is always
looking i don't even know the type of
guy that you like at this point you just
don't know
either but that's the thing i'm figuring
it out
do you like do you do you like dating i
don't like casual dating
and i'm learning that the more i
honestly dread first dates it's the most
awkward thing in the world too oh really
first things are exciting
no because half the time the guys that i
um go on dates with
like we were talking about earlier today
have no social iq whatsoever
but when you when you go on these first
dates right so what are what are your
avenues of dating right now it's it's
online stuff first and then you meet
them in person or are you meeting these
people within a circle and then and then
you start dating them
always in the past it's been through
mutual friends i was pretty
yeah i was pretty late to the online
dating game yeah also with online dating
i only had hinge
i currently still have hinge but like i
don't really care for it too much right
now what's wrong with hinge
nothing's wrong with it it's just i
can't find myself connecting with
the guys that i talk to so it never
really makes it to the date phase
my most recent ex was from hinge but
i haven't found anyone i clicked with
since then
her ex-boyfriend situation is by far the
most hilarious thing is because
she met somebody who was just as
emotionally unavailable as her
just as emotionally stunted
and she's like why won't you show
affection why would you show affection
well that's not how the conversation
went because we had no conversation
oh my well how did you guys communicate
then it was
that was the biggest issue it's just we
didn't
have communication skills with each
other
i'm sure because i mean in the past when
i've dated
like my exes aside from him
they kind of brought that side out of me
by being more open
and learning these questions out of me
so they were like the interviewer
right right so my most recent ex because
he was just like me in this like
poor communication aspect it was just
like
nothing came out from each other i'm
sure he was used to having like
girlfriends in the past
who opened him up a little bit more but
since we were so similar in that sort of
aspect
it was just not a good combination well
how how can a guy
so they're dating you right so how can a
guy open you up then what are what are
the steps that a guy does to to get you
to open up and be a little more
vulnerable
i tend to follow a lead in relationships
okay
so if a guy if i feel like he's a little
bit more vulnerable and willing to open
up and ask me questions
then i will follow suit it's like okay
because you're so open and honest
i will follow suit and just be open and
honest about my personal experiences and
whatnot but this guy
honestly was kind of like a closed book
didn't ask me too many questions so we
just
established a very shaky foundation to
begin with
we weren't toxic or volatile either it's
just
a lot of non-communication
okay when you say like non-communication
it would be you feeling a certain way
let's say you were
upset right so you're clearly upset
about something that he did would you
would you communicate that to him
do you mean that type of
non-communication yeah i wouldn't
communicate it what the [ __ ]
he wouldn't communicate either you guys
are just pissed living together yeah
what the [ __ ] how do you do that i don't
know i don't know how i did that for a
year
it was just a lot of things swept under
the rug i
still to this day have to assume a lot
of things about like maybe
things that he thought because we just
weren't open
about that stuff and i don't know i
really truly don't know how i lasted a
year in that
but i always in the back of my mind and
he definitely knew this too
because we had a talk one time when it
was like a breaking point he was like we
don't
talk we don't communicate so he was
definitely aware of it too
so we were like moving forward let's
work on this but
i think it's just so foreign to both of
us that it's just nobody
nobody knew how to start the community
yeah no one knew how to break that
precedent that was already set
communicating is hard to especially if
you don't know how to communicate and
then
on top of that the the things that you
want to communicate is about
fighting it's hard right because it's
awkward
it's almost like you feel that if you
don't talk about it
because you do care about each other the
problem will just go away and it's never
ever like that yeah
it just blows up eventually you might
have a laugh
here and there that makes you forget
about that in the moment or you might
have a good moment you guys go out to
eat
you eat this great meal you're having a
good time but the next time he does
something [ __ ] up
that compounds with the last thing that
you did and then it's like you
[ __ ]
yeah yeah yeah so it was very unhealthy
in that
particular aspect again like i said it
wasn't toxic
it wasn't volatile we didn't fight but
everything was just kind of
buried and buried and buried did you
feel like you would get more and more
distant from him then
yeah for sure at a certain point i was
like why
why isn't he just well again well i was
just very emotionally invested too
yeah but at a certain point i was just
like
why isn't this ending already we both
know that
we have issues and the foundation isn't
strong why are we still sticking around
each other
when did you start because you guys were
together for at least a year yeah so
when did you start feeling that then
i always felt it since the beginning
[ __ ] i know i'm so
so [ __ ] but i was literally i put him
on a pedestal so i just wanted
to be with him regardless of the issues
that i knew i just decided to ignore the
issues which was
that's why it was unhealthy for me
that's crazy so when we broke up
i was kind of like finally so it felt
good
yeah i was relieved because i knew it
was bound to happen
but i didn't have the strength or the
courage to break it off myself
that's hard yeah i i i was the opposite
so when i
when i found something i really didn't
like yeah it's like hey this isn't
working out
you know and then we kind of it's always
been better that way though and i'm not
saying i was always like that there's
definitely
when i look back at it there are a few
moments where i didn't handle it
correctly
simply because you know it it stems from
a selfish place too sometimes when
um some people say like oh i didn't want
to do that because i didn't want to hurt
their feelings but a lot of the times
especially in my case it wasn't the fact
that i didn't want to hurt her feelings
it's because i didn't want to be in an
awkward situation so it really is more
of a selfish thing right right right
so i was actually just telling one of my
girlfriends the other day
i was like i'm personally suck at
breaking up with people because i don't
want to hurt them
it makes me feel bad but that's the most
selfish thing you could do to the other
person because you're just wasting that
person's time
yeah so one of the things that i was
also grateful for for
my most recent eggs i was just like in
my mind
thank you for breaking it off this soon
because we had so many things planned
we had like a reservation booked at a
hotel and everything
so he could have honestly just waited
until we did that [ __ ]
but you know when push came to shove he
was like okay this is the time to end it
regardless of whatever we have booked
that [ __ ] doesn't matter i don't want to
waste her time and he
actually told me that too when we were
breaking up it's like
i mean i could have waited like i don't
want to end it either but i just know
long term like i just don't think this
is going to go far
so i would be doing you an injustice if
i were to
prolong that dating period yeah so i was
honestly really grateful because time is
so precious to me so i was like
when you when you when you get when you
guys kind of split or you break up how
long is your grieving period before you
start dating again
is it pretty quick no well it depends on
how much i like the guy
yeah the ex before him i was over him
within the relationship i was just like
i'm over this guy
that [ __ ] sucks for a guy when when
you guys kind of come to a conclusion
you go you know what
we're not good for each other let's part
our ways and the next day here on a date
he's like yeah what the
[ __ ] but with the
x before my most recent i
jumped into a new relationship literally
a month after because i was already
emotionally done
for months ahead um so you like being in
relationships that's something that
that's the thing i'm always single for
at least a year between relationships
the last two years was just kind of an
anomaly
for me but now i've been single for
over a year it's already been over a
year oh [ __ ] yeah so i'm i'm still
i still consider myself in the healing
process like i'm completely over him
no feelings whatsoever and i just wish
nothing but the best and i
am so grateful for that relationship
because it taught me so much yeah
but i still consider myself to be in the
healing process because
i'm re-learning how to be independent
and i'm re-learning
you know what makes me happy and i have
time for myself to pursue my hobbies and
passions
i think that's what everybody goes
through when they when they kind of had
this committed relation from what i've
been finding out is that
they kind of lost a little bit of their
independence because instead of a me
thing it was a us thing yeah so
whatever move that you were making
before it was in consideration of the
other person that was a part of you
right so when you make these decisions
to go out go out
go out to eat meet friends or whatever
that it is or whether it's
you know having somebody check up on you
to see if you're okay having somebody
next to you when you sleep
there's this weird adjustment period
where you're just like
there's nobody there yeah what the [ __ ]
this is kind of weird
yeah because i i thought about this too
recently and i had this guy who was a
quote-unquote dating coach and he you
know what i told him was
what he told me was why don't you
imagine you know the woman that you're
with and she's gone what would you do
the next day i was like besides cry
like i don't know i really wouldn't know
what i would be like in
a dating situation i know i'm a very
social person yeah but
being social with the intent of trying
to date somebody is different
you know because if i'm just social and
just talking to a woman just to talk to
her
there's no sweat off my back there's no
skin whatever i'm okay
and i'll just be casual whatever there's
no there's no fear of rejection
there's no fear of me [ __ ] up with
what i'm gonna say
because there's no intent to have this
woman come home with me or for us to
develop a further relationship
so if she comes up and she doesn't find
me interesting i'm like all right
and then i move on yeah there's there's
something very comforting especially i
think for
i'm not sure for women but for a guy uh
being able to talk to the opposite sex
and not have any intentions with it
because you don't really care about the
outcome it literally doesn't [ __ ]
matter she finds you attractive she
thinks you're dumb dweeby whatever a
dork
who the [ __ ] cares i have a woman at
home i'm just here just talking trying
to make friends
so if i go back in that dating situation
i don't even know how i would deal with
it
i probably would cry you would cry in
the beginning
but then you would after that period is
over
like maybe let's say six months later
down the line after the breakup then
if marielle left me i wouldn't be dating
for at least i guarantee you at least
a year like not even probably that makes
sense like not even dating not any of
that [ __ ] yeah
we've we've invested six years of our
lives together yeah so now i'm just i
just have to be reprogrammed it's like
okay when i
you have to literally train yourself to
learn who you are and how you're like
alone
because you haven't felt that for years
now i know so
you would go through a major adjustment
period like i mean obviously i've never
been in a relationship like yours
yeah as long as you a healthy one
oh my [ __ ] god i wonder what that's
like
it's great it's weird you know i i do
know what it's like to be in a bad
relationship
so there there is this odd thing of
i still feel like i have choices right
so
not in terms of i feel like i have a
choice to find somebody else but when
i'm with somebody that i have a healthy
relationship in and we communicate well
it's like i i don't feel confined
i don't feel i feel obligated to her but
i don't feel confined at the same time i
feel like i can speak my mind
and i can be who i am unapologetically
and that's the part where it was like
okay this this girl might be the one for
me because
she was she she has a quality that i
that i didn't realize that i really
appreciated and what the quality is is
her allowing me to be me right because i
know a lot of people who get into these
relationships
that they feel like they have to be a
certain somebody when they are with this
girl
and then when they leave they can be who
they really are right with marielle
because she
she i'm just who i am in front of her
and without
so it allows me to kind of just stay
this one person i remember when i was
younger
um i hated living like a having a
duplicitous personality right i'm not
sure if that's a [ __ ] word i'm just
trying to be smart right now i'm trying
to be steven a smith duplicity
but i felt like around these homies i
had to be this guy yeah
right and then around these girls i had
to be this type of guy then if i was
over here at church i had to be church
boy right and so i felt like i just had
multiple personalities and i had to
manage it so many times and as i got
older
i just stopped caring about that right
right i think that's a younger person
thing
for sure yeah cause i feel that too
though i'm not saying i'm old at all i'm
still really young
but the older i get i notice that more
like the less
[ __ ] i give about what face i'm showing
to group a
b and c yeah she had such a good quality
which i enjoy was when she walked
outside
she wasn't saying oh i don't have my
makeup on that's the first she's
honestly the first girl that i've been
with that wasn't like that
and it was refreshing for me because i
this podcast is brought to you by june b
matcha not all matcha is curated and
created the same and jun b matcha stands
out above the rest
if your matcha isn't a beautiful shade
of green and doesn't have an earthy
smooth taste then you are definitely not
having junebe
matcha is not supposed to be bitter the
caffeine boosts and health benefits you
get from it are the best no caffeine
jitters and loaded
with a bunch of antioxidants to get 10
off your first order of tins and packets
go to junebeshop.com and enter code
geniusbrain once again that's 10 off
your first order of tins and packets go
to junebeshop.com and enter code
geniusbrain you know i know a lot of
guys say this they go oh i don't care
whether you have makeup on or not i
genuinely don't forgive a [ __ ] i really
don't care and the reason why is because
i have to reflect on myself as a guy
if i was so particular about how a woman
looks when she presents herself outside
i should have that same standard for
myself and i have zero standards
you know it's really unfair yes i know
you don't zero standards for myself so
if i
if i feel okay wearing flip-flops and
socks and you know whatever
a baggy t-shirt and some [ __ ] short
shorts and i go outside i can't look at
the woman that i'm with and say hey
i really prefer you to have makeup on
and do this other stuff yeah yeah so
like i think for her because she's not
so self-conscious about those type of
things
i also appreciate that because i feel
and once again this is just my opinion
about the women that i'm with
is that if i always wanted to be with a
girl that didn't care about those things
so much just because i know that when it
comes to physical looks and everything
else
that stuff leaves with you with time you
can't escape time and you can't
escape aging people try it with botox
puffing up their [ __ ] lips all that
other [ __ ] whatever
it doesn't [ __ ] matter you're gonna
die and you're gonna go into the dirt
and as you age i think there's this
grace and beauty that comes with aging
that sometimes women don't get to feel
because number one it's a societal thing
and it's also because guys also have
this thing of saying this [ __ ] like
oh
i don't i like my girl without makeup on
but it's at the same time
are you saying that just to make her
feel good or are you just saying that
because that's just the cute thing to
say
and for me i really don't care yeah yeah
yeah i like that about marielle even
just earlier today i was like doing my
makeup and she was like
oh where's that from it was a pretty
well known brand and she's like oh what
is this and i'm like
dang she yeah she's so comfortable in
her skin and i love that yeah she
she wears makeup uh obviously when she
has to like the most makeup that she
puts on on general is
like bb cream very minimal and then
she'll do her eyebrows
and then her eyes and that's it yeah but
obviously when we go to weddings if we
go out to dinner then she'll do it but
then because she hasn't put it on in so
long
it's like a relearning process oh my god
i don't know how to [ __ ] do this so
it always takes her way longer to do
makeup than most girls because
by the way if you've never tried doing
makeup before and you know when they
started doing the do your
uh boyfriend or girlfriend's makeup
challenge that's the first time
i realized how hard it was it's [ __ ]
hard it's an art it's painting that's
why there are painting artists
and well-known artists for it because
it's literally an art form
as cheesy as they that may sound to some
guys it's literally
the face is the canvas and there's a
painter it's hard
it's it's legit painting and you have to
tailor it to
every face shape and feature yeah it's
it's crazy
when i when i was trying to do so gina
and i did it and this is before mary and
i were together
yeah and i was first of all your boy
didn't do a bad job
i'm telling you after a while yeah you
got that feminine touch though i'm
telling you
after a while pitch finger [ __ ] fingers
did you see these right here
what the [ __ ] you talking about each one
of my fingers are dicks that's how big
they are what you're talking about
but when i was doing her makeup we were
looking at it
and it was for a moment i said this is
almost too good that this video isn't
funny
i was like oh [ __ ] boy you're pretty
good at this popping then at the end i
started doing funny [ __ ] because it
actually started looking decent
and gina was like this isn't bad i'm
like i know it's not bad
at all okay girl i started doing
everything she was nice
well you're feminine as [ __ ] i am dude i
don't give a [ __ ] [ __ ]
but yeah makeup is definitely hard but i
also the older i get the more
you know i don't give a [ __ ] yeah so
we're slightly less makeup too now it's
such a liberating feeling
to really not give a [ __ ] and i think
that
that is hopefully what people will get
to as they get older
because honestly there's a few things
that happen when you get older you start
to realize how
how precious and finite time is right
and i always tell everybody this is that
the only thing guaranteed in life is
death
so it's about what you do with that time
the more time you spend on
on worrying about how ugly you are how
insignificant you are how insecure you
are
that time is wasted figuring out how
great you are so when you kind of focus
on those things
and that becomes a part it literally
becomes a part of your psyche
because just like in repetition when you
become good at some things when you are
repetitious with bad habits you become
good at those bad habits
and so when i see people when they wake
up and they go i ask what's the first
thing that you do in the morning it's
like well i got to make sure i look good
because i don't want people to think
about this
it's you're already telling yourself
that you're not good enough for the
world right
and i'm not saying that you shouldn't
wear makeup i i think yeah makeup is
dope it's art you want to look good you
want to look dope that's fine
but i feel like when you take that out
of your step what even if the guy if
it's
him not shaving or not doing his hair
and you feel like a lesser of a human
being because of it
i think that's where it kind of i have
an issue with it yeah
it's weird because i get a lot of
questions from younger girls
in my instagram dms about like oh
freesia can you talk about insecurity
on your like youtube or whatever can you
talk about how you deal with this and
that about body image and i'm
i'm kind of like i don't know how to
really answer that
because for me just like just stop
thinking about it you know like
i don't like to as soon as i find myself
like dwelling on a certain body
part i'm i kind of like kick myself and
i'm like dude
stop wasting time and energy thinking
about this [ __ ] when you could be
thinking about more productive things in
life yeah you know you're wasting so
much mental energy thinking nitpicking
at body
parts that you can't even change yeah so
what's the point
yeah you're just wasting your own time
and making yourself unhappy and i'm sort
of like
that tough lover but i feel like a lot
of girls that reach out to me are
looking for like that soft
you know like sensitive oh it's okay
like everybody
is like different but i'm just like just
stop thinking about it yeah and also too
like your problems aren't
it's so insignificant you think that
everybody cares about
your [ __ ] [ __ ] calf no one [ __ ]
gives a [ __ ] yeah people just kind of
move on from it people will have
thoughts
and i think we're always trying to evade
like avoid negative comments
you can never avoid negative comments
people will never think you're perfect
people will never
always think nice things about you it's
just it's to the point now where i want
people to say bad things
i don't i i'm not gonna say i don't give
a [ __ ] because obviously words tend to
hurt like they [ __ ] with your psyche
a little bit right but we also have this
control in our lives where we can figure
out
how much it affects us right if it's
just a comment this name and you know me
too
i have fun with this sometimes like when
i respond back and i'm roasting somebody
back people think i'm brewing in my
thoughts it's just
i was taking a [ __ ] and i saw this
comment and i'm like man what should i
say this person yeah right and i'm like
pop pop write it out in my head that's
good and i like that [ __ ]
i'm good yeah but i'm not standing at
home huffing and puffing walking in
circles about how mad i am right
i'm it's just a part of my comedy it's
me roasting somebody back so
you know it's it's difficult man you're
you're well even the generation beneath
you
it's it's just i feel bad sometimes
because of
how much people are allowed to express
their opinions about your life
in so many different facets twitter
instagram
facebook not fine anymore uh freaking uh
right yeah i always say i'm
so so glad that i didn't grow up with
social media i grew up in that awkward
in between where
social media came for me in high school
yeah so
i i don't think i would be the same
person i am today if i grew up from
elementary through high school with
[ __ ] tick tock instagram comments
likes thinking about all the
these numbers i think
i would be like instagram was supposed
to take away those likes and they still
they still haven't [ __ ] some people
don't see it all right i know some
people there so it's happening slowly
yeah i think they need to get rid of
that stuff because it allows you to
appreciate something based on if you
like it or not
man but [ __ ] instagram they're not
they're saying they're doing it for like
mental health but really they're doing
it for advertising oh 100
like i i just don't like that like
number because it's
it kind of forces you to think oh if
this is cool then i should like this
yeah you know but if you like something
you like it if you don't you don't it's
whatever
you know and when you're kind of in like
for example
i i think um like the way
beauty is defined always changes in
every generation right
but right now what i'm seeing more
specifically in la in this [ __ ] city
if there's every [ __ ] girl looks like
a prototype of this of of the same
botched [ __ ] lip job or something
their lips are gigantic yeah
it's it's weird it's like what the [ __ ]
are you doing you don't even look human
anymore yeah but because it looks good
quote unquote on camera
they'll do it for the cat but when they
walk out in public i'm like dog you
look like you [ __ ] mouth wrestled a
beehive
yeah what is going on yeah honestly
i noticed that about la girls because
i'm from new york right
so new york girls are a little bit more
raw and
they rock the no makeup look free the
nipple kind of
and just like very natural yeah but then
when i come to la i'm like damn
you're done the [ __ ] up but you look
great and i mean honestly no shade to
ellie girls because i love my
la home girls out here too but they
really
it's sort of like korea in a way where
they just have one standard of beauty
and everybody tries to look like each
other
which i i totally sympathize with and i
get it but
at the same time it's just like come on
it's hard because when i see that stuff
because if i you know you know i'm at
the age now where i might have a kid so
if i have a kid and she happens to be a
daughter
like how do i tell this young girl hey
you know you got to find
what makes you beautiful right and do
all this other stuff uh i asked my
roommate this i was like what if
you had a daughter and she was like
dad i have a flat chest i really really
really really want a boob job like
she's getting me bun off she's bullied
she literally has
nothing she's like i just want like a b
whatever it is just
something there what would you do would
you be i'd be like listen
i tell you that you're perfectly fine
the way that you are so
as a daughter i don't give a [ __ ] what
my dad thinks about my body
okay but she's but this is assuming
first of all your father relationship is
different from most people
all right i know your background no but
still i feel like i speak for most girls
they don't care about like how beautiful
but but you're saying but you have to
realize how you asked the question you
asked the question as if the girl is
coming to her father for advice
so she does give a [ __ ] about what i'm
saying if she didn't give a [ __ ] she's
asking you
she's not asking about your opinion
she's asking you if you'd be willing to
pay for it
i'm paying for [ __ ] for that type of
stuff [ __ ] you got you get to you're an
adult and play for yourself you can [ __ ]
what you do after that yeah that's what
i would say i'm like
so you don't care if she does it it's
just you pay for it listen it's not that
i don't care
it's just that's your body it's your
life what i always
this is the same advice my mom gave me i
said this on another podcast
after i let's say i'm a parent i would
tell my kid the same thing after i die
you live with your own choices
what you do with your body if you're
happy with it whatever as long as you're
a good person you're making good choices
i have an opinion about what i think you
know you should do and what i think is
mentally sound
however dad's gonna die one day you
gotta live with your own choices
i'm not gonna be around to tell you and
you're not i'm not gonna be around to
advise you on what you do with your body
i can only hope as a parent that i did a
good enough job to let you know that you
are perfectly beautiful the way that you
are
that's it but afterwards you have your
own money you want to get a boob job
because you still feel like you're
less of a woman and less of a person for
me as a father it's going to make me
feel like i failed
however you got to do what you got to do
that's funny my roommate said the same
exact thing
it's like if my daughter gets a boob job
i feel like i failed as a father
yeah well it's it's not even failed as a
father it's like i failed in like
to teach her that teacher about her own
beauty right yeah and that's something
that i'm gonna have to deal with
but it's not something that's going to
kill me on the inside right
but at the same time of course like we
don't want our children
to have to feel like they have to modify
something that god or
whatever person the universe or genetics
gave them right i feel like that's such
a male
mentality because my mom's like girl do
you want a boob job i'll pay for it
yeah i mean i don't know well that's
what i'm saying like i don't know i'm
not a girl yeah
so if my daughter came up to me and
asked me for that at a young age i'd be
like
hell no i'm not paying for it you could
pay for yourself that's your body you do
what you want
your body your choice your money not
mine i was stressed
so hard if i had a daughter i'm like
it's okay like
listen like dude uh my friend gina has a
boob job my friend gio has a boob job
they all got boob jobs i don't know how
many people would google
that i'm a [ __ ] ton of a [ __ ] nina
has a boob job you know all these
[ __ ]
what's up nina oh god
you know and i don't know maybe like
boob jobs to me
aren't as a big deal because they're
under a shirt
you know you know what i'm saying and i
feel like because it's
boobs to me is definitively uh something
that feels like a birthright to a girl
you know what i'm saying like when i
become a woman i should have tits it's a
symbol of what yeah
daddy would give you his tits if he
could you know what i'm saying it will
suck the fat out of these and just pump
it right into yours
but because boobs and this is i guess if
i think about it now it's
boobs to me for a woman is like this is
my rite of passage as a woman and i
never got these so what the [ __ ]
right yeah so it's like me i don't know
not being able to get my [ __ ] or
something or some [ __ ] yeah you know so
it's a little different because it's a
sexual organ i said
to my roommate also i was like if
getting like a dick job
was so easy just as easy as a blue boob
implant because
for anyone that doesn't know or is not
familiar a boob job
is literally literally a same day
procedure like you can go home the same
day
it should [ __ ] hurt so but yeah if it
was just as easy
for guys i feel like so many guys would
get like a dick job
probably you know so like because once
again i said it's a sexual orgasm and it
feels like a rite of passage for a woman
i think psychologically it's a little
different yeah ass job is different
ass you could do squats and you can make
it a little firm and a little bigger and
that's fine if you want an ass job i
think that's ridiculous
right because it's not a sexual organ
yeah it's it's a fad
you know what i'm saying so big big ass
wasn't even big when i was younger
people get made fun of her fat asses and
i was the one that liked fat asses yeah
like why do you like fat asses like
isn't that weird they have it's
so yuck yeah not for me yeah he likes
the booty
right yeah and those things are fads
like i said because this is like a rite
of passage for a woman
i feel a little different about it but i
don't want to pay for it though so you
could go ahead and it's a primal thing
too
from an evolutionary perspective having
huge tits is like a primally like
beautiful thing i'll go for a flat
chested girl any day
as long as that ass is nice and right yo
how do we even get on boobs right now
i have no idea i probably brought it up
yeah you probably had you dumb [ __ ]
but um yeah i don't i don't think i have
a problem with that i think it's more
along the lines of just
you know somebody valuing themselves
yeah and i
i also get to that not everybody has
that outlook that i do not everybody is
as
as open as free as i am like i walk in i
don't give a [ __ ]
like i've gone into uh business meetings
i've gone into
casting i've gone into whatever
flip-flops and socks and a shirt
like even till this day so when i when i
finished the film i got assigned to a to
an agency right and i want to see if i
could act
it wasn't really my thing i still want
to act i just hate going into these
stupid auditions i don't give a [ __ ]
about but i remember when i was
introduced to a lot of these uh casting
directors
and i came in and i didn't know this but
when you have a general meeting with the
casting director most people come in
dressed to the nines
they got their [ __ ] fade right they
making sure that they got
the right story they're doing everything
and when i came in
flip-flops and socks sometimes like with
this like tank top and a shirt and i'm
coming in i'm like
as you always dress as i always dress
and i came in and then one of the
casting directors told me she goes
she goes how refreshing and i'm like
what do you mean
she goes it's just very refreshing to
see somebody who just comes here and
then wants to be themselves
i'm like i was like you oh it's like oh
you told me to come casually she goes
but this is really casual she goes well
we mean casually we mean like
comfortable she goes you look like you
just rolled out of bed yeah i was like
oh i'm sorry i didn't know she goes no
it's not a problem she goes just most of
the times when people come into
these general meetings they try to dress
to impress and i'm like oh i'm just here
to ask you questions because i don't
know about this crazy acting process so
i just wanted to ask you what it's like
what your job is like what are your
criteria for finding great talent
nobody has asked me this before so
usually they they try to tell me their
story i was like
well you don't need to know my story i
was like i just want to know what you do
so i can come here and be a better actor
or
figure things out yeah and so i think
that was a good edge that i had when i
was acting because
every time i went into an audition
almost every time i got a call back yeah
but
it wasn't something that i was trying to
do on purpose i think it's just a weird
thing of mine to
not want to worry about impressing
everybody because it stresses me
out it literally takes my spirit away
for me to walk out and wonder what
somebody thinks about me
makes me die on the inside yeah it's a
waste of my [ __ ] time it's a waste of
energy
i think that's why i [ __ ] with you too
because you're just so unapologetically
yourself you take me as i am or don't
take me at all
which i like because i i'm not as
open about that as you are but that
internally is who i am
so i [ __ ] with that and i relate to that
so hard because i'm
i'm kind of like a black and white
thinker i'm just like it's this or that
yeah take it or leave it that sort of
mentality so you
seeing you doing it like out loud i'm
just like that's what i [ __ ] with
it's just it's a lot easier yeah you
know and it is this podcast is brought
to you by
better help is there something
interfering with your happiness or maybe
you realize that your mental health
just needs a boost or it's something you
haven't really focused on in your life
see this year especially since we've
been cooped up with limited social
interactions we really need to check in
on our mental health i will always say
this but just to say it again your
mental well-being is as important as
your physical well-being
for those who don't know better help is
great because they can match you with
your own professional license therapist
you can schedule your sessions via phone
communicate a message online do video
calls
and you can even change your counselors
if needed if you're at home and you want
to try online counseling give this a try
please i love it and you can too
if you want to give this a try genius
brain listeners i got the hook up to get
10 off your first month of better help
just type in betterhelp.com genius to
get that offer today once again that's b
e t t e r h e l p
dot com slash genius it's also easier on
the other person because it's exhausting
to impress people all the [ __ ] time
yeah and for that other person too i'm
also making it easier for you too
because you don't have to figure out if
if you're somebody who's concerned
whether somebody likes you or not
cool i [ __ ] hate you i hate
i hate your guts so now that you know
this
may god be with you yeah just move on
from me yeah you don't have to and
you could be okay with it people are not
obligated to like you
people are not obligated you don't have
an obligation to their time their
affection
none of that [ __ ] none of those things
are given in life and it's okay
yeah and so there's also the concept of
everybody like i know people men
and actually might have this girl on
this podcast but she has the biggest
issue
with wanting everybody to like her right
and
it's i i see her and i could see
sometimes
when she feels like somebody's not
feeling her out or like not laughing at
her jokes because she's a really funny
goofy girl
i could see her get nervous and i see
her trying to throw more jokes at the
wall
to make sure to make them laugh and
sometimes i just want to tell her it's
like yo this person doesn't [ __ ] with
your type of humor
they don't think you're funny it's okay
but like it eats her up inside it eats
her up inside for somebody to think that
she's either
fake uh she's not funny or they don't
like her for some odd reason because in
her mind she's trying to justify by
saying i haven't given them any reason
not to like me
but what she doesn't realize is that
sometimes people just don't [ __ ] like
you yeah
and that's okay i feel like it's coming
from a place of like
she well she pours her identity from
what it sounds like to me
she's pouring her identity and being
that funny one or being the likable one
so as soon as she gets a feeling and
inkling of like oh
this person isn't aligned with like my
image that i'm trying to portray
she goes in panic mode because it
doesn't align with her identity
so i feel like that's dangerous because
she's not being really true to herself
she's trying to build
this fabricated thing of like
just i need you to believe that i'm
funny i need you to believe that i'm
likable i need you to believe that i'm
this great person
and if you don't think that way then my
identity is crushed
you know for sure because i see my
younger self in like that too because
when i first tried to do when i was
getting into stand-up comedy i remember
when i went to college and at that time
i was doing loose stand-up open mics or
whatever that i could uh before
at that point it was only two years uh
and i just remembered when i went to
college i was always trying to be the
[ __ ] funny guy
and it's you know it worked that's how i
made friends be like oh this guy's
[ __ ] funny
but really i was just working like
honestly stand up comedy sets all the
time see if they thought it was funny
but
there were moments too where i was so
too much you know and i i had to dial it
back
and i'm like i was like this joke isn't
working here i'm like
scratching but i was using these people
as experiments almost and it's almost
like if they didn't find it funny it
sometimes they would crush me because
i'm like
[ __ ] like this i bet you this wouldn't
work well in a set or whatever
but that i do relate to that because
sometimes when you put
um that pressure on yourself and to
other people to find you funny all the
time or be a certain type of thing
it kills you on the inside yeah yeah you
go home and you're like [ __ ] maybe i'm
not this person maybe i'm not that
that's what i'm saying being young
sometimes
dude man [ __ ] sucks yeah it does
speaking of college
can you talk about how we met because i
know a lot of my friends
are always wondering but i just like
never really explained she's a really
[ __ ] loser man
so it was syracuse yeah was it so i met
her
so i mentioned on the podcast before
where a lot of the interactions that i
have with with
either people who bring me out to
schools or even fans it's very casual
i'm a very casual normal [ __ ] dude
like
i'm not i don't ask people to get me
drinks
water i asked for nothing i asked for a
bottle of water and a mic that's it
it's very simple and then if let's go
out to eat after and then i'll go drink
and stuff
um when i met her i remember her because
she this [ __ ] has the silkiest hair
i've ever seen
i was just about to say i remember the
first thing you said to me you're like
what's up silky
she had the silkiest [ __ ] hair and it
was just glistening in the light i was
like
silky i was like daniel hair silky as
[ __ ] says i like hair like it's super
nice and silky but then you know
she she was one of the people that was
showing me around we had a good time
drank up whatever what not
and so i came to either a neighboring
college it wasn't syracuse it was
yeah binghamton i went to binghamton and
then she hit me oh she goes oh i'm going
to be there or whatever no
no no no no no no this is the first oh
you actually did i didn't know you're
there right no i didn't know you were
there either yeah
so i went to binghamton and this was a
last-minute show that i got booked and
signed for
it's been so [ __ ] awkward she comes
up to me
and she goes hi do you remember me oh
okay bye she runs away i'm like
it's because we clicked really well in
syracuse yeah
and i was not expecting to see you in
bigoted i remember
we were in the auditorium or whatever
for the show
and i see you in the front row and i'm
like oh [ __ ] david's here and he's
performing
so at the end of the show i was like
should i say hi should i should i not
say hi like what should i do
because i don't know if he remembers me
so i literally was like [ __ ] i'm
gonna go say hi so then i run
up i literally squat down next to the
seat that he's sitting on
i'm like hi do you remember me
he's like he just looks at me like i'm
the strangest [ __ ] human being in the
world
and then looking at that face i was just
like
okay she didn't even let me respond
i was like as soon as i was like baby
he thinks i'm [ __ ] crazy okay i'm
gonna go
so i just [ __ ] darted oh that [ __ ]
was so f i was like how
awkward and i'm a very awkward cringy
person and i remembered her too
and i was gonna say her name i was like
oh what's so freaky she just goes bye
she just the [ __ ] out oh hello man like
at least let me say your name or say hi
or what's up
yeah yeah but then we ended up seeing
each other at the after party
and then we talked a little bit more
there yeah and then we just hung out
after that anytime i went to new york i
always hit her up
and then it's our friendship from here
or not have i've seen her grow
grow up into an adult graduate get a job
she's [ __ ] nuts it's nuts it's been a
long time six years
five years six years however long you
and marielle have been dating it's about
six years yeah damn
six [ __ ] years man and look at you
all growing up going on dates and [ __ ]
i'm struggling out here dude you gotta
tell the story about that [ __ ] dude
that you hooked up with
oh god this is what the [ __ ] but
she has the funniest dating stories like
i don't know how you meet these people
but it's [ __ ] nuts
and i think it really does have to do
with the uh the online dating aspect
because things kind of move fast yeah
and you don't know
what these people are yeah that's why
i'm like i don't [ __ ] with hinge anymore
so i met this
guy on hinge and i talked about this on
one of my girlfriend's podcast but i'll
tell it again
because it's a funny ass story and
okay so i met this guy on hinge we
talked and i i remember him
because he liked me in the past but i
didn't like him back because i was like
i don't know how i feel about him but
the second time around i was like let me
just give him a shot whatever let's
let's stop being picky freesia
so i give him a shot we go out for
dinner i'm like okay cool you know
not bad not great but whatever i'm i'm
down for the second date
second date he's like do you want to
come over to watch a movie and i'm like
uh
red flag uh what does that mean yeah you
know
that means netflix and chill but i was
kind of like cautious
long story short ended up going but it
was it was fine it was cordial we didn't
touch
even at all not even an elbow so i was
like oh okay
okay i i i kind of [ __ ] with him he's
respecting he's
respectful of my space we're good i feel
safe now
and comfortable so i was like okay third
day he hits me up he's like oh
it was like around new year's time frame
do you want to go grab drinks with my
friends we're gonna do a little
celebration
blah blah she's like yeah cool i'm down
so
we're out and about get drunk obviously
that's when we start getting
extra flirty extra touchy
it's like yeah we're feeling each other
so hard
and then obviously i go back to his
place
and we do the deed we're both
drunk as [ __ ] but then
i see this guy literally index fingers
to
both areolas and starts rubbing his own
nipples and i'm like
in my drunk state of mind i'm like this
is normal this is cool
i like it i think it's quite these
quirky this is [ __ ] normal
you're just drunk frisia and this is
normal but then still
we were going he was still rubbing his
own nipples and like getting off on it
i'm like
okay frieza this is not normal
this is [ __ ] weird um but maybe it's
just because he's drunk so i just
i didn't finish but i let him finish and
then we went to sleep
next morning we wake up he wants to go
for the second round morning sex type of
situation and i'm like
maybe the nipple thing didn't happen i
was like maybe it was just a drunk thing
yeah let's see this is the make or break
moment
so we're doing it again in the morning
he's hitting it from the back i
literally was like a [ __ ]
[ __ ] you better not be rubbing your
nipples i look
back at it real quick and i'm like oh
god he's doing doggy with his fingers to
his nipples
i was like bruh i gotta get the [ __ ] out
of here
so after you know we did that
it's [ __ ] from the back and he's
rubbing his [ __ ] nipples he's not
gripping on you what the [ __ ] he's not
that's why i was like he better not be
rubbing you're like he's not because
usually
guys will grab you or like touch you but
i was like
i don't feel hands right now what the
[ __ ] is he doing with his hands right
now
yeah i was like he better not be rubbing
his nipples because we're sober now
i turn around he's rubbing his damn
nipples what the [ __ ] is that that's so
weird
in my mind i was like why the [ __ ]
are you busting this [ __ ] out the first
time we're [ __ ] like i don't [ __ ]
understand
well if he if if he did that let's say
you guys were dating for about a month
right you've been hooking up for a month
and then he starts doing you probably be
more like i'll be like man [ __ ] i'll
rub your nipples for you
come here baby let me do it what else do
you like
it was just really just out of nowhere
it was i was shook
shook to the core he's gonna listen to
this he probably
won't he probably won't i'm gonna make
sure he gets to if he does i'm sorry
i'm sorry he goes that's the reason why
you stopped hitting me up was because of
the nipple thing i'm so sorry
yeah i literally phased him out he would
keep hitting me up during quarantine
and i just was like sorry that'd be so
funny if he hits you up and the last
sentence he writes he goes
is it the nipple thing is it the [ __ ]
thing i can't help it
i don't think so but aside from that i
kind of didn't [ __ ] with him
because there were a lot of red flags to
me throughout the three dates
or the red flags he wasn't communicative
either so i was like oh i can't
repeat this situation again how is he
not communicative
because usually first second date third
day even you start opening up
more you start like asking more
questions that are deeper
first date not maybe not but second
third day i feel like that's a natural
time to be like oh so like how was
your upbringing or like this or that and
even if i would ask him these questions
he wouldn't reciprocate it's so boring i
mean what do people talk about when they
don't do that
what do you talk about i don't [ __ ]
know
i really don't so to me i was just like
all right like this is kind of like
my ex 2.0 right now and i'm just not
about it i'm not trying to repeat
history right now so
i was very very cautious with him and
then the nipple thing just did it for me
you're like you know what you can't
communicate and it's clear because you
didn't tell me about the nipple thing
and now i know for a fact communication
sucks 100
so when you when you let's say you're
going out for
a a date right and then you see somebody
on whatever app and you know they look
cute
they have on the list uh some stuff that
you might like about them
what are your absolute notes and what
are your must-haves
on a first date uh just about a person
in general we'll go to the first date
after so in general
what's your absolute nose of one of your
must-haves absolute
no is if you are
super conceited and into yourself give
me an example
if i we're having conversation it's all
about oh i did this i achieved this i
do this and no question about me and i'm
like okay
cool you're you're a really cool guy but
i'm not gonna hit you up for a second
date i'm not gonna
answer you know why guys do that [ __ ]
though it's like um
for them they're trying to make them
they're trying to get make themselves
sound good
so you become so they want to be a
qualifier like i am somebody who can
provide i'm somebody who can do this
and i think that that's what happens
with a lot of these like dating advice
guys they go
you got to make sure that you show this
woman that you have value in your life
and so they do that but they don't know
how to do it in a way where it's
balanced
where the the conversation becomes you
just talking about yourself the whole
time
instead of showing value in a social way
that's more like i can be emotional
valuable to you
or available in that kind of sense as
well so they do that because they want
to show you that
oh i'm somebody who has it together but
it comes off as you just been talking
about yourself for the past [ __ ] hour
guy
you know yeah
yeah i mean i've had a lot of like i'll
entertain it though i'll be like of
course you're going to be a [ __ ] yeah
yeah
or dick yeah but one of the key things i
look out for when a guy
is getting to know me is how much he
asks me about me
just because i need there to be a
balance it's it's also kind of touching
upon that social iq aspect i was talking
to you about earlier too
anyone who knows how to carry a
conversation knows the balance between a
you know like give and take yeah so
for me it's like when a guy is just so
self-absorbed in conversation i'm like
he
probably you know is doing this all the
time and like i don't know
maybe i'm just not giving them enough of
a chance but no
i think because you're getting older now
you don't want to have to baby somebody
through a conversation
that's what it is yeah you know when you
as you get older and you start to become
more
solidified and you as an individual and
you know what you like
why should you have to baby somebody
through that [ __ ] it's not saying that
yo
as a guy get your [ __ ] together before
you talk to me it's more like
i i know what i want and if it's not
there
why do i always have to be the person
that has to build this human being
into a functioning person you know yeah
i think i have a lot of alpha tendency
so
second thing i really look for is like
alpha qualities because i i can't have
beta
but you sit here [ __ ] you eat this
so i'm weird and i'm still trying to
figure out what the [ __ ] it is that
works for me and what i want but when
i'm in a relationship i'm beta
but i'm still alpha as a human being in
my own individuality
but i need someone in the relationship
at least to be alpha
so as soon as i feel beta energy i'm
like nope you're out
oh like that that dog with the tail
between their legs like when they
ordered they was like oh
what do you want to eat so go what do
you want to eat yeah i like guys that
make a plan
decisions done it's like we're gonna go
here and here
and you're gonna like it i'm like okay
okay and i'm gonna punch you in the face
really that's right tomorrow i'm kicking
you with a [ __ ]
i'm gonna kick you in your [ __ ]
beta-ass [ __ ] [ __ ]
oh my god please make love to me now
[ __ ] me and rub your nipples
no but i like guys that's why you didn't
like the the nipple rubbing was very
beta of him
probably probably and also
you know one of my ex is not the most
recent one but some of my other exes
they were just two beta for me so i lost
attraction oh
so the guys that i've broken up with
have always been beta
that's weird because like for me i don't
think uh any girl that i've been with
has ever said on beta but i'm not
somebody who makes plans i just kind of
like
whatever you want let's just do it yeah
you know i don't like that
at least for first date if we're in a
relationship [ __ ] it i don't care
because let's just go with the flow but
in the initial courting stage i want to
be led
oh that's kind of cool i mean that's
just a very specific thing i've realized
that i'm pretty traditional
you know like i i want to be that person
who's like breaking boundaries it's 20
20 like you know guys and girls should
pay equally but i'm like
yeah i kind of like to be taken care of
i like to be the girl i like to i like
the
standard traditional male and female
role
so that's why i like the alpha energy in
my partner
i think that's perfectly fine everybody
has their own preferences and tastes
like uh
recently uh not too long ago like my
buddy gina she found out about herself
she goes
i'm just tired of me trying to be like
they're people trying to define what a
strong definitive woman is and
i just want to be taken care of why
can't i just say that why can't i just
be in a relationship where i have a guy
that takes care of all the bills or
whatever
and i just want to be that hot woman
that's [ __ ]
cooking at home and taking care of your
needs it's like that's true
i mean that's you taking control of your
life and saying you figure out what you
want why why the [ __ ] not because there
are guys that are 100
like i want to be that guy that provides
yeah so it's just
[ __ ] not me david still like an eagle
progressive david soap
split that bill [ __ ] so like first date
for example
i will always genuinely be willing to
pay
i will be willing to pay but
if they let me i'm gonna be like no no
second date why are you playing games
[ __ ]
no no it's not it's not second it's not
games it's like
let me see what kind of person you are
that's games
that's you testing somebody on a date
yeah i mean
is it games i mean it is you testing
something first thing that's the
testing you know what the funny thing is
i actually don't like that i don't like
it when somebody tests me like on their
human subject
so my thing is like you say what you
like and then you let me know
but i'm not i'm not gonna be like pay
for this oh for sure no but i am
but my thing is it's because i don't
know your preference i don't know if
you're
kind of 20 20 and very millennial and
one split the bill or i don't know if
you're more traditional it's like i
gotta take care of it
i don't know as first date i don't know
that's it's so weird that's all
preference it's like for me so i'm i'm
okay with either or
but because i'm learning that you're
more of a dutch player
and like you like things more equal when
we first go out we don't dutch pay i
always pay
yeah exactly so it's just courtesy to me
that it's just a symbol so i want
i think a lot of guys like the courtesy
for me i'm just like
don't even offer so like even no even
with like me
offering to pay it's not coming from a
fake place because i am sure for sure
i'm genuinely willing to split it but i
that's when i know like we're not
aligned because i want someone who's
willing who wants to genuinely wants to
you know take me out but i also think it
depends on who asks out who because if i
ask a guy out then i'm going to pay
but that's that doesn't work yeah it's
really rare that i've
i think i've only been asked out by a
girl maybe twice yeah right and it was
just
i don't know if the word is refreshing
it was just interesting it's like huh
i don't have to ask how odd but i would
always pay though
i don't know if it's because it has
nothing to do with male ego it's just
something that i was taught
so it's it's i have to do it yeah you
know it's like
i'm not traditional i'm gonna do this
you know it's almost weird
but you know when when after we've been
together for a while and we know each
other's finances i'm like you make money
[ __ ] pay for something [ __ ] yeah what
i'm saying this right here this
tortellini
that's on you man yeah yeah yeah here's
the thing for dinner it's like since you
asked me out
i'm expecting you to pay but dessert's
on me let's go for a second round if i
like you
let's go for second round it's on me
because i obviously it's not as much as
dinner
but it's like because i like you and
because you are willing to pay
i want to like give back a little bit
that's dope yeah so
second round is always on me even drinks
and stuff there was one guy that i went
out with
on we made it to two dates he didn't i
actually paid for the second date i was
like let me get it let me get it because
i let him pay for the first date i was
like let me get it he didn't like that
he was
he was drunk as [ __ ] but he was like i'm
a girl man i could take care of this
[ __ ] on my own
like that's a weird one yeah so that's
why i didn't make it to third date
because he also got [ __ ] drugs like i
can handle my liquor this guy could not
handle it well he's socially awkward you
don't you don't say it like that yeah
sometimes people don't get it oh god
they don't actually i mean i gave him
leeway because he was [ __ ] up
still even when i'm [ __ ] up either way
i was like okay this guy has like an ego
issue so [ __ ] this whatever
you know i really do believe it's true
when people get drunk the
truth comes out the truth comes out and
also too the type of person you are only
becomes
exemplified right so uh i've seen people
who have a lot of rage issues so
i'll tell you this for example this is
just coming to my mind uh went to a
wedding not too long ago with a friend
and uh it was a friend's wedding with
the super last minute you know i
actually showed up in just like
jeans and a shirt because i flew in that
day for his wedding i wasn't gonna wear
a suit i told him like yo
i'll be there for the reception i'll be
there and now i'm going out tomorrow
really dope and there's a lot of friends
who i knew in high school
and even college that they're nice guys
they're super nice guys didn't have a
temper problem at all
right but whatever that's inside them
internally started coming out when they
were drunk
and they know they know me i used to
have a very [ __ ] short temper
and so but i've been just i'm a lot
nicer especially when i'm drunk i'm
extremely nice because i'm always i
always want to have a good time
well then i started to see like the real
personalities of these people because
when they got drunk
and for me i didn't drink that much at
that wedding because i was going to
drive and i started to see who who these
people really were
and i don't know whether it's because
some of these guys didn't get to do what
they wanted in high school because they
were really nice people or
even in college but some of their
[ __ ] tendencies started coming out
and i got
[ __ ] mad and a friend of mine who was
there he could tell
because we've been friends for like six
seven years he can tell when i'm getting
really irritated
he's like oh you said you're getting mad
aren't you i was like yeah because you
know these guys are saying some [ __ ]
yeah so i'm just gonna give you a couple
examples there was two guys that were
there
and they're like i mean honestly both
you [ __ ] are little [ __ ] you
know you guys are right like i'm a
little [ __ ] too
but you guys are definitively [ __ ]
you have never been in a [ __ ] fight
in your whole life
and they're sitting there mouthing off
to people like yo [ __ ] this [ __ ] like
first of all this is what i mean by
people who are socially awkward right
yeah it's not about what you're saying
it's about how you say it so
we're sitting at the table yeah and then
we're talking about i forgot the
conversation of food came up
and one of these dudes were like yo i
want to get some chick-fil-a and this is
what this fool says out of nowhere he
goes
[ __ ] chick-fil-a cause they don't like
gay people [ __ ] gay people hating
[ __ ] and we're having a good time
what does that have to do with anything
we're like we just want a sandwich yeah
and we're just saying we like this
chicken he's like nah [ __ ] that [ __ ] now
he's acting all mr tough guy now that
he's drunk
i'm like oh that's who you are right
you're this little angry
angry little short guy and that you want
to be mr tough guy now that you're drunk
so i'm sitting there really quiet and
i'm staring at him
right just staring at me he's like right
dave i [ __ ] chick-fil-a i just didn't
say and i kept looking at him and my
friend really grabbed my arm he starts
taking him away from him i was like no
no let him pop
cuz i'm getting [ __ ] mad yeah because
we're i was having a good time and i
wasn't drunk yet
because if i was drunk i wouldn't even
care i'll just be like whatever [ __ ]
chick-fil-a
yeah i hate it you know yeah me too yeah
me too but i was getting super irritated
and then my other friend too he was
really drunk and this is what
that's what i'm saying this is where
their true personality starts to come
out this other guy super nice dude he
comes up
and then we started telling like old
funny stories from back in the day and
we were telling embarrassing stories
about each other and i started
mentioning this one
and dude comes up to me and he goes like
no don't tell that [ __ ] story
or i'll [ __ ] you up he says this to me
at the [ __ ] table at the wedding and
i'm like
what'd you say to me right he goes i'm
gonna [ __ ] you up you said and i thought
he was joking at first
and i was like oh he's joking i'm
getting [ __ ] mad you say i'ma [ __ ]
you up and i just remember looking at
him
and i go bro i was like you have never
hit somebody in your life
you tell me you're gonna [ __ ] me up one
more time i'm gonna slap the [ __ ]
[ __ ] out of you yeah and we're at this
wedding
and i kid you [ __ ] not he goes like
no i don't like it when people do that
[ __ ] like i'm not no [ __ ] and i just
[ __ ]
bop slapped him in the face i was like
oh my god and i'm smiling and we're all
joking everybody's laughing
but i was irritated i was like you go
hit me go hit me hit me yeah right
and we're all having a good time he's
like oh it's like a [ __ ] hurt i was
like don't tell you
don't say you're gonna slap somebody
when you do that [ __ ] i'm like you guys
are [ __ ]
like you guys are [ __ ] [ __ ] and
their real personality came out when
they were drinking and i hate that so
when i see somebody like that
that's who he really is like that guy we
saw today
oh yeah same [ __ ] yeah you know what i
mean it's like
you guys are dicks you have something
that you're dealing with on the inside
and is coming outside right
and because i have rapport with them
obviously if it was a random person most
likely would have broke out into a fight
right but i wasn't going to let him come
up here and say he's going to [ __ ] me up
in front of everybody and he's over here
like grabbing my shirt like like my
collar my shirt like this
i'm smiling at this point and i'm like
yeah like
you don't forget i just i'll [ __ ] you up
bro like don't don't put your hands on
me like
that's sloppy drunk yeah and i'm i don't
like being around people like that so
when you tell me about this guy who's
just like
no i could handle my own [ __ ] just like
no you a little small dick energy bro
yeah
you're probably like literally yeah i
was just like okay
i'm still paying for it so i don't like
that whole drunk excuse stuff right
and afterwards too you know when the
wedding was over or whatever they
messaged me and they were like yo my bad
man i heard i got a little aggressive
and i was like
yeah man like you [ __ ] grabbed me by
the collar of my shirt i was like i was
like yeah i'm sorry if i slapped you but
you [ __ ] grabbed me you know i would
have [ __ ] you up because i yeah thanks
for not stalking me bro i'm like yeah
man like don't do that [ __ ] like we're
we're old friends but it doesn't mean
that you get to just grab me and do
whatever right
i don't know what happened to him i have
a little bit more sympathy i understand
where you're coming from but i have
sympathy too for drunk people
because i love to drink by the way can
you pour me another glass
this [ __ ] is literally drinking
i know but i really really truthfully it
comes from
it comes from genetics i truly believe
it
but uh i love to drink and i have done
stupid [ __ ] in the past too that was
very out of character
and literally the next day i would be
like why the [ __ ] did i did that i don't
believe that it was truly
my internal self coming out i was just
blackout drunk and stupid
so i sort of sand but i mean you know i
drink too
but i know you you're more controlled
though yeah i get
wild listen we we definitely drink a lot
but it's just
i don't know i don't maybe it's because
i don't think that i would even give
myself that type of sympathy
you know maybe i understand like if
somebody i think it's the aggression
part that bothers me
because when people get blacked out
drunk and i think they're just happy
people they get blacked out drunk and
they do happy people [ __ ]
yeah so it's just if you know you're not
in a good place don't be drinking
because drinking only
only heightens that emotion that you're
feeling at the moment
it's like a korean thing too they say
don't drink when you're when you're when
you're sad because it only makes it
worse
after breakups i don't drink it's it's
the worst literally
it's waterworks i don't care there was
literally
one time uh that i was out
at a bar with my girlfriend and she was
asking me about my breakup
i was totally cool cool as a cucumber
dog walks in because my ex and i well i
my ex had a dog that was very very
invested we had him as a puppy
so i was kind of like the caretaker part
two
and i was i just love dogs i love
animals so i connected very heavily and
i
maybe i over invested i don't know but
for that relationship dogs are strong
association
so i was i was very cool talking about
the relationship when my girlfriend was
asking me and then a dog comes into the
bar
and i just start bawling oh my god oh my
god it wasn't even
it wasn't even like a big guy it was
like a [ __ ] pug and i'm like
that dog is here at the bar oh my
god dude but it's true like when you
drink
i guess your very very deep internal
emotions come out
yeah but i have i've also said some dumb
[ __ ] when i was drunk and totally didn't
mean it
what did you say i don't i can't even
name it because there's been so many
times
get your [ __ ] life together i know
okay so what we said we said there was
what are your uh
must-haves oh yeah and then what are
your cannot haves or
must-nots must have
in a relationship right i really want a
guy
that prioritizes
his mental and physical health that was
never important to me
until recently the older i got like the
more i'm like oh like this is
actually really important so you want a
guy to be fit and active and then
you don't have to have a six-pack but
you just need to carry about the health
of your
like be active and you know yeah yeah
yeah because
that's something i recently picked up on
a little over a year ago i never gave a
[ __ ] about what i was eating what i was
doing and how active i was i just took
everything for granted but
uh there was kind of like a switch that
happened in me where i was like
wait frisia you have you're the only one
that's gonna take care of like the
internal [ __ ] that's going on in your
body everything
your lifestyle right now is so [ __ ]
unhealthy you eat whatever the [ __ ] you
want
you drink like a [ __ ] korean dad
that's facts and
this [ __ ] is gonna take a huge toll on
your body in the future and no one is
gonna take care of it except for you
like are you [ __ ] cool
you want that standard in yourself so
now that that's a core value in me
i want it to be a core value in my
partner so that was never something i
looked out for but now it is
and what do you mean by mental health uh
i need you to
be able to reflect on
your mistakes your past and grow from it
and kind of not wallow in your self-pity
yeah and just be like mentally healthy
you always want to grow and strive to be
better and learn from mistakes
okay yeah it's interesting like let me
ask you something because you you like
alpha qualities in men
what do you are you okay with the guy
crying
in front of you depends on what the
subject is if it's
see i guess this is a little touchy
because
i don't want to play god and be like
judgmental about it but like
this is just a preference yeah if it's
like over some dumb [ __ ]
what is dumb [ __ ] like i'm crying
because like
you didn't come during sex i've had a
guy cry because of that get the [ __ ] out
i [ __ ] find him [ __ ] not a guy
cried and shed
tears because i didn't finish during sex
and he thought it was
like on him and i was like what the [ __ ]
is going on right now he cried he
[ __ ] shed
three tears why what what is it what why
i was just like wait what's wrong you
[ __ ] i gotta get the [ __ ] out of this
like your [ __ ] just dried the [ __ ] off
yeah that's nuts like that type of [ __ ]
i'm like
what the [ __ ] are you crying about what
did did you ever discuss it with him
like the reason
i asked him i was like what's wrong i'm
i was just like i'm sorry i don't do it
every time
i i just that's a lot of girls don't do
whatever i don't i it's really hard for
me
to be honest just to be frank it's so
[ __ ] hard for me to come during sex
you want the interesting so i've i've
asked you know because i have a lot of
girlfriends right you know this
but some of the girls that that i've
talked to they said like yeah like it's
it's not easy like if i have to come
usually i have to be the one to start it
or or something else that way
and that like penis and vaginal sex it's
damn near impossible
and then so or i have to use toys or it
has to be in the right mood i have to
use toys
yeah so during sex like this same guy
that cried
bought me my first vibrator it was like
a tiny bullet vibrating yeah
but after i used it i was like oh [ __ ]
this is like a game
the one that's going to do it yeah
because i've never
had an orgasm through penetrative sex
yeah ever in my life
and i still don't know what that's like
because some of my girlfriends are like
what
you're [ __ ] missing out but then i
have a lot of girlfriends that are like
that's normal
i mean i have more the other way around
where most girls don't
like yeah yeah yeah like the only time
that they've uh
like came from like penetration was like
the stars aligned
you know what i mean like the [ __ ]
date was perfect
the day was right they were feeling each
other and then for some reason it hit
the right spot and they came
but most of the time they're the ones to
either induce it or when they have sex
they don't really need to come and
they'll do it on their own later on
the only girls that i know that have
genuinely came during penetrative sex
is when they were on top for some reason
yo so i that's so funny so um
one girl that i was with she could she
would always come during sex
but the only position is if she's on top
and what she told me was because
she's in control and she could hit the
spots that she wants right so it's
essentially her using a dildo
whenever she was on top she would come
super fast also every vagina is
obviously different yeah like i think
the placement of the [ __ ] on your body
is yeah
it plays a huge factor because on top
i'm like it doesn't do it for me
yeah because for her it was kind of nuts
where we
when we were hooking up we couldn't i
didn't want her to be on top because she
would come too fast
i'm like hey you're having too much fun
you can't come that fast because after
she would come she's just
she's exhausted because the electricity
would happen yeah yeah and i'm like no
no no no
i'm sorry i'm like okay well we can't
have you start on top then we got to
switch it up
but for her it was i mean i guess that's
a blessing for her you know but i know
yeah and i think listen i'm not gonna
knock okay i'm knocking on the dude for
[ __ ] crying but i know
there are there's a conversation that
people have
where guys feel like they need for the
girl to come because it makes them
feel like they've they've i'm a man i
can really [ __ ] do it
but when you have conversations with
women and i always say this too for guys
you can't know about a woman from
another dude because a dude is not a
[ __ ] woman yeah you gotta talk to
either close home girls or maybe some
people who are sexologists because they
will tell you the honest truth about
this stuff a
every vagina and every dick too is
different
b most of the girls are lying to you
when they say that when they said
they've come during sex
or when they pretend they're like they
don't want to hurt the guy's ego that's
the thing
i have no ego i'm just like if if you
create a very genuinely
open and honest place then the girl
might be like yeah i never came
yeah even with the girl who who used to
come always on top i i
thought in the back of my mind like are
you you don't have to do this for me
like i don't need it she was like no
it's just
it's the thing like if i'm on top i've
always came really fast
so i was like okay it didn't do anything
for me it didn't make me feel like a
[ __ ] man yeah it was just you're
using me woman
you know like we got to switch positions
up because you can't keep finishing
before me
instantly yeah like she was fast with it
i don't know maybe that's a that's a
blessing for her
but she was somebody who didn't like
toys she didn't like um
maybe that makes sense because for her
clitoral stimulus stimulation was too
much
it would it would be extreme for so she
didn't like it if i would like if we
were [ __ ] out play with her [ __ ] she
hated that [ __ ]
so for her that probably makes she says
low tea
maybe her vagina is low tolerance maybe
her [ __ ] would just [ __ ] fly off
and i'm like this was too fast for me
yeah
it's very individualized too so it's
it's case by case so [ __ ] funny that
he cried
he [ __ ] cried was he a very emotional
person yeah he was
that's extreme emotional though like i i
can't but this is what i learned over
time i can't [ __ ] with
very very emotional guys because it just
doesn't match with me
it doesn't it doesn't turn you on it's
really what it is right
it's more of that beta energy that i
don't like
yeah because i think there's a good
balance for for a lot of guys i think
when we say
and and some people might think of this
as oh this is you know toxic like men
are allowed to cry
because i know men are allowed to cry
too but everything is due in balance and
people have preferences about what they
want to see
yeah yeah you know i don't i know i
sound sexist as [ __ ] which is fine if
you think that but
it's really just my personal preference
and what works for me like it might not
work for my girlfriends my girlfriend's
kind of like the soft side of guys
and that's completely fine it's
literally just preference like height
like
you know sometimes people might prefer
six foot and over some people
are okay with like five five which is
fine it's just i can't believe a guy
cried because i know is this the first
time you guys were having sex or
no it was like after a couple times so
you came the first few times and then
no i never did then why the [ __ ] is he
crying because he never made me do it
also
so by the time i can't do it oh
my god what the [ __ ] well did he ask you
did he
communicate when you say hey he tried
really hard because he
he took it because i told him i never
ever came
through sex ever so he's like oh
it's a challenge it's [ __ ] and then
he cried like a [ __ ]
he tried really hard but because he
couldn't do it he [ __ ] cried like a
little [ __ ]
[Laughter]
i mean that's we i i mean it's just it's
what you already told him then it's like
i don't cry from pen
i don't cry i don't i don't i don't i
don't cry from penetrative sex okay i
don't cry
if you hit it from the back and you rub
your nipples i cry but she
that's [ __ ] funny dude how odd i've
never heard of that before
his very sensitive soul that's that's
that's a bit that's he's
that's more like emotionally volatile
yeah that's like some [ __ ] that he has
to deal with in his past maybe he did
that when he was a kid when he couldn't
finish his projects it frustrated him
and it makes him cry i don't even know
that's so odd he was never a serious
thing but it was
not even an ex-boyfriend but he goes you
said yeah i don't really come from
penetration he goes oh you don't do you
whoa you've never had this dick before
tried once tried twice three times i was
like go ahead and try
with my
when you have sex right um if you don't
come are you okay not finishing yeah i'm
because it's still
an enjoyable experience to me yeah i
don't need to finish every time and
every guy because they
come every time they're like what that
sucks but for
me and for many girls it's more of the
emotional connection and the act it
still feels good
i just don't climax but it still feels
good
yeah it's still like for example kissing
kissing feels good
doesn't make you calm but it feels good
it's like you're crazy i don't know
these guys i bet you that guy would come
though when
he [ __ ] kisses you oh [ __ ]
but you know for example kissing too and
hugging skinship that kind of stuff it
makes you feel good
same with sex it makes in it's a little
bit more elevated than skin [ __ ] but
yeah
you're still connected and it still
feels good there's just a lot of
maximum point and i feel like this is
just me anyways
and mind you like i haven't had crazy
amount of sex partners i haven't i
haven't even hit the double digits i
think sex partners that maybe had eight
or nine right
and so from from that number or so like
when you hook up with somebody
like figuring out when you have a
long-term relationship i always call it
like girls are like an old toyota
like you have to figure out what makes
them run yeah it's not just this push to
start it's
oh you're you're different like work for
the last girl won't work for this girl
100
yeah so when guys talk about like oh
dude i [ __ ] i know exactly what women
in the line it's like you don't know
what
every [ __ ] woman wants you have to
ask questions sometimes and you have to
be comfortable enough where they'll be
open enough
to let you know what their stuff is
because that's where the communication
part always bothered me and i had the
biggest crash course
was when i was uh we were have
the serious relationship part only
lasted about a month but it was that
girl i was telling you about that was a
little crazy
for her she was my crash course and i
told the story before because i remember
she told me the line of men that she had
before i was like i think my date game
is pretty good and afterwards we hooked
up and i was like
so how was it she goes it was all right
now
what what you mean it's all right she
goes you know you just do weird things
like i don't really like it i'm like
oh [ __ ] this kind of hurts she was
friends with benefits though right
we were hooking up at first and then i
don't know when she told me this was
when we were
trying to be serious or not i i don't
know the timeline because i always feel
like friends with benefits are more
honest
she was brutal though she was [ __ ]
straightforward as [ __ ] so when she said
that i
i was kind of like yo that kind of that
kind of hurts a little bit made me cry
i was like okay hold on a second i
didn't make you calm
but uh when she told me that that was
when i started to realize how important
communication was is when
i had to figure out what made her tick
and then you know obviously that
figuring out process was
a lot harder than i thought it was going
to be i'm like okay well she likes this
she likes that i'm like man sex is
exhausting
i was like this [ __ ] is exhausting when
you care about somebody and you want
them to be satisfied you really do have
to be mindful of
so tailored it's very tailored that's
[ __ ] like a suit baby
not just with girls same with guys every
thing that makes a guy go off is
different for the next guy
guys are a lot easier than women though
guys are a lot easier it is it is
because they will still come at the end
of the day but things that certain guys
like the other guy might not like
yeah i think that's just with anything
but i and i genuinely believe though
guys aren't as particular
right if they if they think a girl's
[ __ ] bad as [ __ ]
they're getting [ __ ] they're like [ __ ]
it was ty yeah you know what i'm saying
but a girl if she thinks this guy's
super cute and his dick game's weak it's
like yo that dude's got cute
but his dick game's [ __ ] weak yeah
you know what i mean so girls are
definitely a little more specific about
that type of stuff
because a guy too like for example
majority of the times i've had a hand
job
hated it yeah because you you you'll
never stroke a dick like i know how to
stroke my own brain right you know
so that more in conjunction with the
[ __ ] feels really great but if it's
just a hand job it's like
you're not you don't know what you're
doing yeah i know my dick better than i
was like i'll do it i'll do it
let go let go with my first boyfriend
ever this is
a senior year of
call no no senior year of high school
going into freshman year of college
that was the most open and honest
relationship i've ever had
but we were really young and just felt
so [ __ ] comfortable with each other
so we talked about this very openly but
he would literally
teach me like how to hold it what felt
the best and just try to like imitate
the way he would do it
like oh this is how i hold a dick
babe that sounds really weird it's like
when you hold a dick
i was just so open and willing to learn
though but i've never had that level of
communication with anyone after him
yeah well because i think handjobs two
are so different because even
even like with the girl and when they
come hand jobs are different because
the pressure is different yeah yeah like
depends i like pressure speed everything
depending on who that girl was with
before she tailed it to that guy
so if that guy like if i was when i
hooked up with the girl right and she
would get sometimes they would grab that
[ __ ] like
like she was like there was a thousand
dollar bill inside my dick she was
trying to squeeze it out
like yo what the [ __ ] are you doing i'm
trying to get rich [ __ ]
i'm like yo what the [ __ ] but because
the guy before
like really [ __ ] firm and tight and
then some of the girls would just
barely hold it and it's just like what
are you doing i barely feel this [ __ ]
you know like don't even do it i feel
like if i ever got into the game again
i would be a lost cause it's been so
long for me
[ __ ] is dry out here it's cold [ __ ]
what are you talking about
no the nipple guy was the last time but
back in january he's super happy that's
right the last dick you got
that was the last time you got some dig
but it's it's coveted though so
yeah you know it's different it's
different situations yeah yeah yeah yeah
no you don't know what's gonna happen
i probably sound like a [ __ ] to
everybody but i'm really
i don't think you sound like a [ __ ] a
lot of people too i i am more
experienced than my girlfriends though
to be fair you know what i found out
though a lot of these girls too who
would talk about how many times
and i think this is a general truth i
think the girls that i know has actually
had more sexual partners than the guys
that i know
because girls are a little more uh
demure and they don't talk about it as
much until you become really close
i'm like miss your number is high what
do you consider high
i'm a good christian boy okay okay but
it depends on your age
so if you're 30 and your number's like i
don't know like
15 to 20 i'm like whatever because
you're 30 years old you've
you've been around a lot longer if
you're [ __ ] 16 and your number's like
20 or 30 i'm like yo slow it down a
little bit yeah
you know so i don't know it it depends
i'm older now so i'm 32 and somebody
tells me they've
had 20 or 20 or 25 partners i'm like i
mean 30 something years that's like
less than a partner per year you know
does body count matter to most guys you
think
depends on who you are i feel like body
count low-key
it matters to a lot of guys i don't i
personally prefer a woman
who has more experience because
i don't have to be there to teach them
everything right right somebody somebody
else already did that so i don't have to
have the
some people think about it the opposite
way where they go well now i could
tailor this
teacher yeah so i can tailor this person
i feel like most guys are like that they
want to be
the one to explain and mansplain like
this is how it goes
like i want you to be less experienced
so that i can show you the way
it's most guys with the ego issues [ __ ]
that [ __ ] is so much explanation that's
just exhausting man but they like to
be the one to have more experience it's
just the principle of it
let me tell you something guys i don't
know if you're if you're one of these
[ __ ] dudes and i know i've been
drinking a little bit now
if you have to [ __ ] somebody and they're
older and they're a virgin
they haven't had any experience that
[ __ ] is exhausting that's weird
uh a girl i've i've been with a girl who
was a virgin
she was exhausting not exhausting it's
not her fault right right but it was it
was like
the sex just wasn't good yeah because
she doesn't know what she's doing she's
not comfortable with her body yet right
it's not even so much that she's not
good at quote-unquote sex it's because
she's not comfortable with herself
so i have to be emotionally available to
allow her to be comfortable or she can
be a little more experimental well she
can do things that i like
and that that that process takes so
[ __ ] long
it's exhausting it's really hard yeah
and so if you're that guy that's just
like oh i want what's like the [ __ ] a
virgin let me tell you something here
bro a pussy's a [ __ ] and a [ __ ]
bounces back like a rubber ball
doesn't matter what the [ __ ] goes inside
yeah that should still stay nice yeah so
it's
it's this weird concept like i heard
about that though like guys who who like
virgins
it's a principle it's the principle it's
not the tightness or anything it's the
principle it's like i want to be the
first
the first to what [ __ ] away columbus
she's not tainted she's
pure she's innocent i want to be the
first and that's like a lot of ego issue
[ __ ] that dude yeah i i honestly with
guys though for me
personally i want a guy with a [ __ ] ton
of like
sexual history okay let's just not uh
let's get a little too far
over here i want a guy to [ __ ] 99
[ __ ]
at least at minimum no no
i just want him to thousands come with
experience ah
just bars yeah oh yeah
bars [ __ ] no but i just want him to
have experience so that
he just knows what he likes and knows
what he's doing that's it that's really
it
i would just the only thing that i would
require well i'm with somebody now but
what i a requirement for me was i need
that girl to be able to communicate
you if you're not having a good time
when we're hooking up
that's not on me because you didn't tell
me what you liked and what you disliked
so at that point i'm just shooting in
the dark i'm only doing what what the
person liked before
so if you're like oh it was okay cool
and you're not telling me what you liked
or disliked then that's on you
you're the reason why you didn't come
you didn't let me know sometimes it's a
little awkward to have that conversation
though you gotta let me know
right i don't give a [ __ ] yeah if a girl
tells me like yo like okay i like this
and then i'm like cool
next round the open space for that
conversation though needs to be
created i feel like for sure yeah but i
but that's the preference that i like i
like people who are a little more open
so if i ask is like
uh if we if we hook up a few times and
you know it was good but i'm like
hey like what's what's some stuff that
you would like me to do next time or
what do you want to try out yeah yeah
if i say that and you go nothing but
then later on you're like i didn't like
it
honestly i would love if more guys asked
me that
it's easy guys it's makes it more fun
fun you'd be surprised that how many
guys don't even
initiate that conversation it's an ego
thing they think they know the best
they think they're hitting it the best
they think they're doing a great job
so they don't bother asking let me say
something [ __ ] made me nervous
everyone watching and listening ask your
girl
am i doing it number one it makes sex
way better
100 it makes communication better and by
the way too i think a lot of guys are
intimidated by [ __ ]
i was super intimidated by [ __ ] and i
you know and i based off
what i thought women would like based on
what guys would say to me and i'm like
[ __ ] that [ __ ] well everything your
boyfriend's or
for me yeah okay
everything your boys are saying so
[ __ ] skewed you gotta take it with
many grains of salt yeah because it's
just
their ego talking most of the time it's
like oh yeah i hit that [ __ ]
like she was moaning like a [ __ ]
like she was she
really [ __ ] she was wild whatever but
from a girl's perspective that could
have all been an act dude man
i feel so sorry for my very first
girlfriend she probably had the worst
dick in her life
because i didn't know what i was doing
and she also wasn't somebody that would
ever communicate what she liked yeah so
we were just having terrible sex the
whole time terrible everything yeah and
i i didn't know but
you were also young i was super young
and i was 18. yeah when are you dying
no one knows what they're doing yeah
sometimes it's like if i was singing i
was like i want to run it back
like [ __ ] let's run it back i've
learned so much you know i could do
better
yeah and she could do better too like
honestly when i look back at the sex
that i had when i was 18 years old it's
probably the worst sex i've ever had in
my life and it's definitely the worst
that she's ever had it's probably like
jackrabbit sex
it is it really is it's all that
rarely i mean there was foreplay and
stuff like that but i'm not really
you just don't you're not really
thinking while you're doing it you're
just seeing red because you're like oh
this is a vagina i'm horny and i'm horny
and i need to have sex
i hate the word horny it's so gross
horny
horny horny what about aroused all right
aroused aroused aroused is it's
it's more civil it's very civil nobody
wants to say that [ __ ] though it's like
yeah no one says i'm a razz but no one
says i'm horny or guys say i'm
what's better than horn because i feel
like horny and aroused are in two
separate sections
what's the one in the middle i have no
[ __ ] idea
you want to [ __ ] or what let's [ __ ]
have you heard a guy say that to you
before no no
like if they would they would be slapped
well i'm saying like if you're having a
good time and you're feeling it
no never i think i set that standard in
the beginning it's like i'm not that
kind of girl
i'm not that kind of girl let's [ __ ]
later though
you have my number you have my number
hit me up later though i gotta make sure
everybody knows
i'm not that girl there's been a lot of
times where i've been booty called and i
just straight up ghost them
it's like i'm not that kind of person so
[ __ ] out of here how
dare you booty called me you have not
showed me your nipples yet
no but if they booty call me i i take it
as a side of disrespect and i
immediately just cut them off
you know what i what i've noticed too um
a lot of uh young like asian girls
who were either hyper religious or very
sheltered
they are the ones that um aren't very
communicative about sex
like they don't they're shy they're
super shy and it's because they've been
told that you know
sex is bad you shouldn't do this blah
blah blah they're shamed for it that's
why
yeah i mean i grew up in church too and
i was even [ __ ] a youth group
president
and i had my whole purity rig and
everything and
granted i lost my virginity like i never
met a girl who had a purity ring
that still had it and they actually did
it to the t and then these [ __ ]
yo my seventh grade health teacher was
teaching us about
sex and i was like excuse me i have a
purity ring i'm never gonna have sex
until i'm married and he's like we'll
see what happens
and i was like whoa that was [ __ ]
rude but then
years later i'm like oh i know what he's
talking about now hundred percent
that's just in the dumpster i got so
many [ __ ] funny church stories
i can't even count i could do like 30
podcasts just about funny church stories
yo
i remember this one girl who was a
church leader right i'm talking about
her
her view of sex was so skewed
uh she was talking about she was still a
virgin right this is two separate
stories two different church people
right
i'll talk about the first one oh god
this girl why am i about to cringe
very rough around the corners and stuff
and she was like super adamant about you
know christ's love and everything else
which is dope i appreciate that [ __ ]
your boy's still here technically still
a christian so um
she would talk about sex and i remember
uh one of the dudes like
you never done you never hooked up or
anything and she was like she's like no
i'm not gonna have sex till marriage
but this [ __ ] knew the guy that
she was [ __ ] [ __ ] around with
right and she was like he was like
nothing he's like you don't he's like
you never had sex
and she was like she was like no i would
never die like i have i have uh
i have a some i have what's the word i'm
looking for i have uh
an image to uphold and he goes you
sucked my boy's dick yesterday she goes
is that sex i'm like [ __ ]
oh my [ __ ] buy a technicality you're
over a [ __ ] deep throating dick she
goes
he goes like you [ __ ] sucked his dick
yesterday in his car and just roasts her
ass in front of us right and it's like
it's like three or four people work
really close right she goes that's not
[ __ ] sex she goes that's not sex
like just on this weird moral high horse
now like you've
if you're sucking dick you might as well
just be [ __ ] at this point like
creating boundaries to make yourself
feel better but
exactly it's the same [ __ ] and he was
like he was like getting on her he was
like
you're saying like he doesn't he hasn't
fingered you or anything yeah i would
have been on her ass too yeah [ __ ]
shut the [ __ ] up i was like come on yo
you want to hear the worst one though
so there's another person that was a
church leader right and this is after
she was engaged right and she was
talking about how uh
you know some of the people are kind of
raw and she was i'm like yeah like i'm
so glad i'm gonna get
married blah blah blah and you know i
haven't had sex because i saved myself
and doug we got her ass because we know
the the guy that she was dating before
or like
i thought you [ __ ] you were [ __ ]
right she goes no
i was like yeah you guys were [ __ ]
what are you talking about she goes
he didn't come inside me so it's not sex
oh
lord jesus christmas what
the [ __ ] are you talking about that's
what i'm saying
these purity little chastity it's like
people will find their way around having
sex
that and they're trying to rationalize
it by finding these [ __ ] loopholes
it's like the whole thing where it's
like if it was like we're just gonna uh
well what's the word i'm looking for
what's it it's not a
is it just an inch or some [ __ ] like
that right where is it just the tip just
a tip
just a tip just a tip it's not sex just
the tip is [ __ ] sex at that point
that sex if it's in it's in it's in
doesn't matter how much i
never the [ __ ] thing when she said he
didn't come inside me so it's not sex
made me want to kill myself if the dick
went anywhere near your mouth or hole
it's in you're basically done yeah that
is what it is you're not a virgin
you're not the i'm that relationship
okay
that's okay for sure and the
relationship with sex i think in the in
the religious sense too it's like either
either you're 100 or you're not yeah
there's no in between
yeah yeah but a lot of girls too and i
think um they they feel really
uncomfortable especially the ones that i
knew that grew up hyper religious
um they have this very uncomfortable
relationship with their body
uh and sex especially when it comes to
their own sexuality
like how they communicate with sex how
open they are they lie about like how
many people they hooked up with
because there's that shame that's
attached to it and i always thought it
was audited it's very detrimental for
your
for your sexual partner because you're
not going to be opened up with them and
you have to be
because after a while too when you're
having sex with somebody for a long
period of time
you're gonna have to switch things up
and if you're not being communicative
about it
then it's just it's just it sucks and
what i found out too from being in
long-term relationships too is like in
the beginning
like you're you're always like hooking
up like rabbits that's how it is and
then when you start being comfortable
with somebody and i'm not saying this is
how it is for everybody
it's the same thing every time yeah like
for me i started to realize it's like
oh i don't really need to have sex that
much i think when at first
you're just [ __ ] like rabbits because
it's so brand new but after a while it's
just
i almost feel a fulfillment just being
around the person having that person
there
and i don't feel like i need to be more
connected by having sex so when we do
have sex
it feels really really good so i don't
need to
justify our passion by sex we justify it
in different ways like we're just being
around the person i'm like oh
this took a while to get to and this is
really [ __ ] nice like i like the fact
that i could just
be next to you and not have my dick hard
all the time it's like
i can think straight like this is great
we could have conversations and every
time we're in bed next to each other i
don't want to always have sex
right which is dope it's not because i'm
not physically attracted it's not
because i don't want to have sex
it's now that i i feel i think it's more
of a security thing i feel very secure
with this person you're stimulated in
different ways 100
yeah and it takes a while to get to that
point i can't relate because i've never
been at that point i know you ain't at
that point yet but it's a different
[ __ ] feeling and
um yeah i i at first when i when i
remember when i had that feeling
especially like with mariel and i
started feeling that i'm like oh i think
i really like her a lot it's like i
i i don't need to justify our the
passion in our relationship
to this very specific physical thing and
now
it's like when we're in the mood we're
in the moon and if we're not we don't
have to force things we don't have to
pretend like we have to do this it's
just like oh
this is nice yeah we really remember
when we talked about we're like yeah
it's like
it's almost like the the sexual part is
even better
now because now we're being more
selective about it which is kind of
interesting i'm like oh this is
i'm a grown-up oh because before her
i've only been the relationships that i
had were very short
super short so when we were meeting we
were [ __ ] because we
i mean we're together for what two
months yeah three months that's
[ __ ] period yeah this is always
[ __ ] all the time yeah
and then if it was a long distance
relationship it's like the moment you're
here we're [ __ ] morning day and night
and then we see each other for three
days that's all we do we go out to eat
we come back we [ __ ] and then after that
they they're back on a plane somewhere
else so those those moments of happiness
were very temporary so
i wonder how other people feel about
that though yeah
sex is i feel like it's so different for
everybody though
yeah it's it's very i feel like also
relationships
not that i've been in a long-term one
but especially in long-term ones you
have to go through highs and lows to
figure out what works
for sure i feel like that's what i'm
observing from all the long-term
relationships that i know
and sometimes too like well i've i've
talked to other friends who've been in
the relationships longer before
before like even my personal
relationship when i got to the six year
point the five-year point
they told me like yo we've been together
for ten years and we gotta mix [ __ ] up
like we gotta do some [ __ ] weird [ __ ]
sometimes because we've been [ __ ]
each other for [ __ ] 14 years
never hooked up with anybody else so now
we got to be a little more creative like
role playing and [ __ ] and doing all this
weird [ __ ] and i'm like hey you got to
figure out what works for you
if you need that type of stuff you have
to she goes yeah like i've been having
sex with the same person
same moves same everything and it's not
like the sex is bad it's just more like
i gotta switch it up it's like like
steak is great like i could have steak
for the rest of your sensitized
yeah i kind of steak for the rest of my
life yeah but sometimes i want steak
with a little fog raw butter on it
yeah i'm saying sometimes like a medium
rare sometimes like a medium so we got
to switch it up a little bit
yeah do you think human beings are meant
to [ __ ] the same person for the rest of
their life i don't think so i don't
think so either i think
animalistically yeah people are meant to
[ __ ]
multiple people but again i'm not
a polygamist storyline anyone who's even
open to an open relationship
so it's a little bit weird for me to say
that but
from a very animal primal
perspective i feel like people are not
meant to some people like the new
experience
and uh kind of the explorative thing
about their sexuality
in my opinion when i've heard from other
people versus
finding what's really good for you right
so for me when it comes to sexual things
i
prefer to have somebody that knows what
i like and knows what i
dislike because for other people it
might be like oh this is the same thing
but it's like yo this took a while for
us to figure out
right and i don't want to have to go
through this with somebody else it [ __ ]
sucks man especially when i went from
one relationship we're hooking up when
we finally figure out a good flow
and then we go to the next and then i
have to go through it again scratch i
was like [ __ ] man
it's like you're grabbing my dick too
hard yeah i mean or then i'm like
i'm like thrusting too hard or i'm like
not hitting it right at the right angle
or
she doesn't like doggy style she doesn't
like missionary yeah everyone's girl
every girl's favorite position is
different yeah what's that what's a
sexual thing that is a must for you and
a must not
must you must be dominant okay of course
alpha i kind of like it softly rough
if that makes sense does that make sense
you just want to feel like that person's
in control
yeah but they're not over here stalking
you in the eye and she's no no no no no
no like bdsm type of [ __ ] yeah like just
in control taking lead
for me as i like in my relationships for
me i must know
is i will never have anal sex i've never
done anal
i don't like it i'm just like yeah i
tried i tried it a little bit once
and i hated it oh really it wasn't my
idea no
that's a lie it was both of our ideas
and i was curious
and me no like i knew what actually i
don't know was it my idea
i think it just we kind of got caught up
in the moment because i never wanted to
put something in the butt
yeah because the idea of it because
poopy comes out of it yeah yeah yeah so
the idea that
[ __ ] comes out of there listen i'm okay
with like let's say
we're [ __ ] around and they want me to
like ring the outside of her ass with
the finger or something like that's okay
yeah
sticking my dick all the way in there
and by the way too i found this out from
a gay dude
anal sex too is a process you don't just
stick your [ __ ] dick in there you
have to warm it up
you have to you actually have to douche
it out you have to clean it out or if
you don't
[ __ ] will get on your dick oh [ __ ] it's
it's a whole process
and so like this gay dude is like you
know straight people are so [ __ ]
funny he goes
you think that you just start [ __ ]
somebody in the ass and it's clean like
in porn it's like no we gotta
eat clean like the next day before and
then on top of that we gotta douche it
out clean it out
because if not you're gonna have [ __ ]
all over the place like you don't just
start [ __ ] somebody in the ass
oh my gosh yeah so i learned that [ __ ]
and the funny thing my buddy joe he
tells a story where he had sex with his
girl and she loved anal [ __ ] and he
[ __ ] her in the ass and then when he
pulled his dick out a piece of [ __ ]
dookie
was at the end of his dick and it almost
made him throw up oh [ __ ] god no
oh my god yeah because if you have a
decent sized dick it's going in like
holy [ __ ] it's going in quite a few
inches yeah i've never done anal i don't
plan on doing you know maybe it's
it fits with my husband sure if you guys
have to figure that [ __ ] out
it just depends on what you're
comfortable with if you want to make him
happy and
like my ex wants to do you know i was
just like yeah nope
next yeah i don't i don't like anal i
don't like i don't want it to happen to
me
i don't want to do it to her yeah it's
just because poop comes out of there i
don't like i said i don't mind yeah
that's my mentality too it's like
why the [ __ ] would you want to stick
your dick in that hole like i said i
don't mind like
fingering it or something like that
that's okay with me because it's the
outer edge
but going all the way into the guts i'm
good in the intestinal linings i am good
i don't want to deal with that it's
because of those horror stories like
imagine sticking your
dick inside of an ass and also a [ __ ]
piece of [ __ ] comes out at the tip of
your dick
yeah that's my must never i i just don't
i'm not okay
sexual must never yeah and it sucks too
like it's like from somebody and they're
like well i need this then
we're definitely gonna have to go
through some um some sex therapy for
that because
i that's that's a hill that i have to
kind of climb
because it's not going to be easy for me
a must
a definite no for me or something that
turns me off
is when a guy has no rhythm i want to
like just it's just like
it's just very quick and like not
controlled and just like
very primal and it's like monkey like
i'm like
what the [ __ ] are you doing like that's
gross
i'm sorry but take a chill pill go with
the flow go with the rhythm
you like that [ __ ] r b sex oh i do
you like that r b
sex no but i one of the things i look
out for and someone i date is
how well they can dance because it
translates to the bed
he can't dance we're not [ __ ] if he
can't dance
i'm sorry but
it kind of like it makes me it forces me
to envision how you would be like in bed
i don't like having sex prob like just
smashing because it makes you come too
fast
yeah and it's just it's a lot of work
it's very exhausting
but i feel like guys who want to [ __ ]
like that i think there's moments where
that can happen right it's like when
you're when you're [ __ ] with somebody
when you're [ __ ] and then there's
this moment where it becomes super
intense and then they want it
hard and fast but then you can't do that
from beginning to end you cannot
it's it's number one it's exhausting
it's going to hurt and then on top of
that too you got to switch it up a
little bit you can't just start [ __ ]
like a rabbit from the beginning yep
which when i was 18 definitely did that
and it was that weird thing of like
i'm just trying to come yeah yeah you
know i'm not thinking about my partner
at that point
and then later i figured oh there's a
there's a rhythm to this [ __ ] there's
four play
which is very important for some girls
like for me four players girls
almost all girls for play is actually
important for me too like if i gotta go
straight to [ __ ] it almost makes me
feel like
maybe because i'm an emotional guy it
makes me feel like i might as well just
jack off yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
i mean like i might also just jack off
she's like sort of like get to the point
and which is like not a sex
sexy mindset to be in yeah yeah i know
some dudes that don't even like
they don't like kissing when they when
they have sex that's so weird to me
yeah some people don't well if you're
hooking up if
yeah if it's just a hook-up relationship
but if you're with somebody i think
the kissing part is like the intimacy
that i enjoy but if it was somebody that
it was like i was hooking up with
uh we don't need a kiss yeah it's a
little too personal right i'm okay
yeah you know yeah but i know people who
are with
their partners and they just don't like
to kiss kiss when they say
they just like to they'll do everything
but kissing
that's so like unfamiliar yeah you know
what i mean it seems a little uh uh
distant very distant i don't know i
don't like that [ __ ]
i don't like that at all me neither okay
that's my must-have we gotta
if we're having intense sex we need we
need a kiss yeah yeah yeah okay
okay what else is another must-have
uh must-haves for me
different positions we can't just always
[ __ ] missionary we can't always
yeah if we just if there's one position
absolutely not like when we have sex
in that period that we're having sex we
need to flip it up two three different
times 100
yeah you can't just do one position yeah
no way and then
another must-have is i think for every
guy they need to have blow jobs
like that part is hard for me i didn't
realize how important it was for me
because for me
blow jobs are a part of foreplay so
it's like i feel like it's a part of
both
for what foreplay and like during oh for
sure
but like for me that's important because
yeah yeah it's
it just switches it up yeah you know
what i'm saying like that's like having
like i'm i also enjoy like hand jobs too
but
i i need it to be switched up like we
can't like the only form of like
copulation can't just
be straight sex like penis into vagina
so if a girl just doesn't like she's
like i'll never do blow jobs it's like
well we cannot be together
huh girl you gotta go you gotta
you gotta oh you have to you really do
i i think it's important i i this like
i'm saying like some girls that i know
that where the church girls are like
oh i don't do [ __ ] so foul yeah it's
so foul so gross i'm like
good luck [ __ ] yeah like good [ __ ]
luck
yeah yeah
i honestly enjoy giving head
because it makes it gives you turns you
want for the weight that yeah gives
me pleasure to give the guy a pleasure
yeah
so i will voluntarily go down yeah i
think
i i think a lot of girls will like that
too it's not the i think that's the
thing that those girls who
who say that they don't understand that
concept
it's it's like yo this is a turn on
because i know that i can turn my man on
just by doing this one thing and it kind
of gets it that's why i'm saying it's a
part of foreplay
it's yeah you're not really getting the
sensation of sex but you're getting the
sensation of knowing that you're really
controlling this guy like you're making
him turn on
yeah and that's the fun part yeah yeah
yeah i don't agree with guys who want to
[ __ ] but won't go down on a girl
though yeah
[ __ ] that i think that is that [ __ ]
have you ever been with somebody who
wouldn't do that no
actually once once once they were just
like no
well i never really asked but it was
just like i could tell it was someone i
was
only hooking up with but i could tell
there was such an imbalance between the
times i would go down versus
how many times he would go down i'm just
like very selfish
very selfish very selfish you have no
manners
[ __ ] you but i mean it wasn't a deal
breaker either because
again it was just a hookup for me at
that time oh cause it's not important so
i was just like whatever [ __ ]
[ __ ] this dude i don't really care yeah
yeah would you would you
tell the guy that he would that you
would want for him to go down
no because he wasn't important enough
so i could just cut him out oh so it
didn't really matter yeah yeah
i don't know i i wonder if like do do
guys really do go down on the ground
when it's just a casual hookup
all the time i feel like that's more of
a i feel like most guys would do it
after like you guys hook up maybe a
couple of times and then it's like okay
i'm comfortable enough where
this might happen yeah yeah yeah i feel
like
ah i feel like it just depends on the
guy
it depends on the guy if a guy's more
willing because some guys are like if
like me it gives me pleasure to give the
girl a pleasure so some guys are just
willing and from the first time they're
just willing
so i'm just like oh okay okay yeah but
other guys like
literally are just like [ __ ] this i'm
just trying to get off
on my own it's really dependent on the
guy
it's really dependent on the guy oh sex
is just an odd thing man
it's so personal it's it's very tailored
to each individual
i think it's it's important for for any
young person to kind of hear that too
because you think that you're supposed
to get it right the first time there's
no formula
yeah and it's gonna i think it's gonna
generally either feel
good right if that's what you like but
later on just like anything else it's
when you start to understand that the
nuances to sex is when you start to
really tailor it to yourself and it
starts to feel
different than you when you have your
nose you have your yeses you have your
half knots and your
have yeses or whatever what not like
it's it's then it starts to become
something else i'm like oh this is
this can be really fun yeah it's crazy
because you just
need i can't i can't be like be a hoe
go out and sleep with everybody because
i mean that's also kind of dangerous to
encourage to people i feel like but
at the same time you just need
experience to learn what you like and
don't like
yeah i mean there's people who believe
that they're like well i want to create
a lasting bond with somebody so i'm
gonna save myself
it's like you could save yourself i
think that's perfectly fine yeah i i
just think that from so different from
what i've seen is
um i have hooked up with girls who
haven't had a sexual partner
and it was not the best for
me you know it was it was hard
emotionally it was hard on them yeah and
like i said it had to do with them being
comfortable enough
to be comfortable with me to finally let
me know what they liked and disliked and
going up that hill was was treacherous
it's like oh god did i have to go
through this
again like i already went through this
when i was younger i had to do it again
and again rather than hooking up with
somebody was like okay next time can you
try this
i'm like thank you thank you for letting
me know yeah
cause now i'm not guessing in the dark
it makes me feel it makes me comfortable
right you know yeah because now we can
actually enjoy ourselves
openly yeah she's like dominate me punch
me in my [ __ ] lips and then i want to
wake up tomorrow
oh no i don't want to be abused
so you don't like stuff like slapping or
choking and stuff like that i like
choking
i don't really like slapping though
maybe on the ass
well i'm not talking about the face but
no some girls love getting slapped in
the face
which is weird to me because it's a
little bit hardcore for me but
punch me my stomach now give me the one
two three give me the hook
give me the hook let's do what we
practice you just tell your numbers one
one two one two three one two three
oh [ __ ] that'd be weird what would you
do if a girl was like
[ __ ] left talk the [ __ ] out of me uh
i don't know if i could do that yeah
that's kind of weird
it's kinky i was taught not to hit a
woman but if a girl wants to be slapped
like slapped fine punched no like if a
girl wants to be
i mean we would have to be really
committed in order for her to say that
to me but if we're hooking up
and she's like i want you to sock me in
my face because she could say anything
after that point
i i can't i can't do that [ __ ] though
but i don't mind like
like physical [ __ ] if a girl wants to be
slapped choked or whatever i'm okay with
that [ __ ]
it's just a lot of work that's
exhausting
it's exhausting being mean no i've been
with a girl who who's
so particular about her sex like in
terms of what she likes and dislikes
it was just too much you know like in
the terms of
having sex with her almost felt like a
job yeah yeah yeah right because
do that don't she had to come every time
and she knew her buttons and her toggles
and it's easy for a guy to come right
she goes well you when you come
like you do it every time so i would
like the same back i'm like i understand
that when you say it verbally
but [ __ ] you got so many tricks and
dingle dongles to you
it's exhausting for me berries to you
all you have to do is suck my dick with
your hand and your lips and i'll come
you know depending on what i want you
know like it could be fast it could be
either [ __ ]
five minutes or it could be 10 depending
on how we want to do this [ __ ] i'll say
but for you
it's like okay let me just tell you the
specifics that she wanted she always had
to start out
with with oral first and after oral
okay i had to play with her [ __ ] right
and then
she like the majority of sex doggy so
i'm always doing all the work
and then i'm doing missionary and then i
have to finish her off by doing oral and
this is a whole like 20 30 minutes
experience
that's a very selfish experience it's
exhausting
because she knows that because she wants
to come first because she knows that
after i come i'm exhausted yeah so i
always had to go first with her
and this [ __ ] it didn't annoy me but i
just knew that having sex with her was
going to be an
ordeal yeah i have to be i have to take
a couple of red bulls
at least she knows what she likes yeah
well whoever you're with
good luck to him because that [ __ ] is
exhausting
yeah i'm glad she communicated with me
yeah but the fact that she had to come
just wasn't for you oh it was not for me
she has to be with somebody who
really really enjoys sex in that way of
getting off by serving somebody yeah
yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah because it didn't feel
very for so you know i would come to of
course but it just didn't feel very
fulfilling fulfilling it was almost
exhausting it was almost like if i
didn't do this task
i was not considered a good partner and
i'm like okay you
you're too much it's like i want you to
burn wax on top of my forehead
and i want you to stamp i want you put a
stamp on top of it
and then seal it like a bourbon whiskey
bottle like [ __ ] i'm not doing this
maker's [ __ ] i say makers and they
spit in my eye
oh i hated that oh no well everybody
that wraps up this episode of a very
open genius brain podcast yeah i didn't
know this was going to turn into a
sex you let the conversation there baby
it might be the whiskey it must be the
whisper this [ __ ] had half my bottle of
suntory hibiki
oh [ __ ] i'm glad you enjoyed yourself
this is for guests
well you could find freesia at freesia
park
on instagram that's f r e e s i
a park and you can find her also on
youtube yeah i do a little bit of
vlogging here and there
still still experimenting with what
works for me but
i'm posting actively so subscribe
check her out well we'll see you guys
every thursdays and sundays you don't
know what you're gonna get on a genius
brain podcast and we'll see you all
next time peace peace